we've talked a little bit about the law
of demand which tells us all else equal
if we raise the price of a product then
the quantity demanded for that product
will go down common sense if we lower
the price and the quantity demanded will
go up and we'll see so a few special
cases for this but what I want to do in
this video is focus on these other
things that we've been holding equal the
things that allow us to make this
statement that allow us to move along
this curve and think about if we were to
change one of those things that we were
otherwise considering equal how does
that change the actual curve how does
that actually change the whole the whole
quantity demanded price relationship and
so the first of these that I will focus
on the first of is the price of
competing products the price of
competing competing products so if you
assume that the price of actually I
shouldn't say competing products I'll
say the price of related products
because we'll see that they're not all
they're not all competing the price of
related the price of related products is
one of the things that we're assuming is
constant when we it's being held equal
when we show this relationship we're
assuming that these other things aren't
changing now what would happen if these
things changed
well imagine imagine we have other say
other ebooks other other ebooks other
ebooks books is price price goes up the
price of other ebooks go up so what will
that do to our price quantity demanded
relationship if other ebooks prices go
up now listen my ebook regardless of
what price point we're at at any of the
price points my ebook is going to look
more desirable at $2 it's more likely
that people will want it more people
will want it because the other stuffs
more expensive at $4 more people want it
at $6 more people want it $8 more people
will want it $10 more people want it so
if this were to happen that would
actually shift the entire demand curve
to the right so it would start to look
something like this it would look
something
like that we'll call that will call that
scenario that is scenario one and these
other ebooks we can call them
substitutes for my product so this right
over here these other ebooks these are
substitutes substitutes substitutes if
people might say oh you know that other
book looks kind of comparable if one is
more expensive as one is cheaper maybe
I'll read one or the other so in order
to make this statement in order to stay
along this curve we have to assume that
this thing is constant if this thing
changes this is going to move the curve
if other ebooks prices go up
it'll probably shift our curve to the
right if other ebooks prices go down
that will shift our entire curve to the
left so this is actually changing our
demand it's changing our whole
relationship so shifting demand to the
right so let me write that so this is
going to shift shift demand demand so
the entire relationship demand to the
right I really want to make sure you
have this point clear when we hold
everything else equal we're moving along
a given demand curve we're essentially
saying the demand the the price quantity
demanded relationship is held constant
and we can pick a price and we'll get a
certain quantity demanded we're moving
along the curve if we change one of
those things we might actually shift the
curve well if you change this demand
schedule which and/or change this curve
now if we there are other related
products they don't just have to be
substitutes so for example let's think
about scenario a scenario to where maybe
the price of a the price of a Kindle
goes up so the price of a Kindle the
price Kindles let me write this this way
Kindles price Kindles price goes up now
the Kindle is not a substitute people
don't either buy an e-book or they won't
either buy my ebook or buy a Kindle
Kindle is a complement you actually need
a Kindle or an iPad or something like it
in order to consume my ebook so this
right over here this right over here is
a complement
it is a compliment so if a compliment
price becomes more expensive and this is
something that's one of the things
people might use to buy my book then it
would actually for any given price lower
the quantity demanded so in this
situation if my book is $2.00 since
fewer people are going to have Kindles
or maybe they've used some of their
money already to buy the Kindle there
they're going to have less to buy my
book or they'll just fewer people will
have the Kindle for any given price it's
going to lower the quantity demanded for
any given price and so it essentially
will shift it'll change the entire
demand curve it'll shift the demand
curve to the left so this right over
here is scenario two and you can imagine
the other way if the Kindles price went
down then that would shift my demand
curve to the right if the price of
substitutes went down then that would
shift my entire curve to the left so you
can think about all the scenarios and
actually I encourage you to think about
draw Emmure self think about for
products it could be an e-book or it
could be some other type of product and
think about what would happen
well one think about what the related
products are the substitutes and
potentially complements and then think
what would happen as those prices change
and always keep in mind the difference
between demand which is this entire
relationship the entire curve that we
can move along if we hold everything
else equal and only change price and
quantity demanded which is a particular
quantity for a particular price holding
everything else equal